Let's consider that we want to transmit a message
which is made up of four words, A, B,
C and D. And let's assume that all the
four letters are used equally in the language. They
occur, the frequency of each letter occurring in the
language is equal. So, you can be present A,
B, C and D in binary, with two bits itch, each, like so. Which means if we have
a sequence such as zero, one, zero, zero, one,
one, the six bits spell out the word BAD,
bad. So basically we'd require two bits or symbol. Other way to
look at this sequence is that you need to ask two questions to this sequence
to atleast recognize one symbol. So, two
bits per symbol also means that you have
to ask two yes or no questions per symbol.
Now let's consider the second message to be made up
of the same symbols but in this case A
occurs more frequently than B, C or D. D of
course more frequently than B and C. and, let's
assume that these are the probabilities by which we can
see A, B, C, or D. Now, we can do the same thing again, we can use the same
binary representation to represent A, B, C, and D. So again, we'll end up with
two bits per symbol. But can we do
any better? Well, A occurs more frequently than
the others so can we somehow use this to our benefit and use a different bit
representation to get slightly less than two bits
per symbol? Think about it. Can you think
of a new representation that might be better?